I was so incredibly depressed that I
wanted to not wake up every day so I
would go to bed hoping that I wouldn't
wake up and I knew that I was not
satisfied with the job that I wanted I
knew that I wanted to start a business
the conclusion that I had to come to for
me to make this move despite my father
who had a tremendous amount of influence
over me was I can either die to him or I
can die to me and so I knew that by
leaving this path and quitting and then
starting a gym especially in the Middle
Eastern world where you can be a doctor
an accountant you know I mean me being
in business was already like kind of I
was pre-med originally because his plan
for me was I was going to take over his
practice and it made sense on paper the
guy makes a million bucks a year I get
the argument but I would have been dead
inside the entire time and I would have
been in prison for my whole life when I
did make that move we barely spoke and
it was only after not only that I had
made more money and then made more money
than he'd ever made he did the dynamic
shift to one where he respected what I
had done and it took probably almost a
decade